Розгляд у Парламентській асамблеї Ради Європи став
кульмінацією скандалу з українським законом про освіту.
Вперше за кілька років українці у Страсбурзі
були в ролі не ображених, а  кривдників.
Темою розгляду була дискримінація українською владою нацменшин.
Дискусія, ініціаторами якої були Угорщина та Румунія,
була короткою, резолюція – суворою.
У новому українському законі, наголошується в ній,
не забезпечено баланс між офіційною мовою
та мовами нацменшин і право щодо навчання рідною мовою.
Критикують українську владу і за те,
що не були проведені консультації з нацменшинами,
зокрема угорською на Закарпатті.
Та що акт було направлено на експертизу
Венеціанської комісії ПАР'Є
вже після його ухвалення й підписання.
При цьому депутати ПАР'Є посилаються перш за все на
Рамкову конвенцію щодо захисту нацменшин,
яку, на їхню думку, порушив Київ.
Ця критика стала болісною для України,
яка звикла спиратися на підтримку парламенту в Страсбурзі.
Українська делегація заявила, що резолюція містить
подвійні стандарти та що вона чекатиме висновків Венеціанської комісії.
Між тим, у ЄС вважають, що Київ не має
сидіти склавши руки.
Замість додавання олії у вогонь,
Україні слід врахувати критичні зауваження.
Зокрема, негайно вступити в діалог з Угорщиною та Румунією,
аби зменшити градус напруги.
Тему мовного конфлікту між Києвом і Будапештом
будуть змушені розглянути міністри закордонних справ ЄС.
Берлін хоч і не поділяє багатьох антидемократичних
ініціатив угорської влади, та все ж не бажає
подальшого нагнітання пристрастей. Будапешт розкрутив цю тему
аж до того, що вимагає заблокувати
асоціацію України з ЄС.
Тож Києву слід, імовірно, готуватися до перегляду статті 7
закону про освіту. Перший бій у ПАР'Є вже програно.
Наступний - у Венеціанській комісії.
Там на запит DW відповіли,
що оцінювати український закон експерти
будуть у світлі стандартів Ради Європи
у сфері викладання мов.
Зокрема спиратимуться на Європейську хартію регіональних мов,
а також Рамкову конвенцію про захист національних меншин
та зобов’язань України щодо цих документів.
Висновок Венеціанської комісії щодо закону про освіту
очікують до кінця року.